[Musique]
vous croyez pouvoir me guérir d'une tu
n'es pas malade
l'esprit est une chose fragile
le moindre petit choc peut lui faire
prendre la mauvaise direction
charles qu'est ce que tu as fait devait
la stabiliser je lai protéger
de la vérité
et bien un autre mot pour ça je suis
venu chercher des réponses à mes
questions
tu pense ne pas être à ta place ici
finit pas
ils sont incapables de comprendre ce que
tu es
se transformer
en quoi
ce ne sont pas des réponses que tu
cherches tu es venu chercher une
autorisation
[Musique]
elle n'est que fureur
douleur et tout explose en même temps
jean ne se contrôle plus mais elle reste
notre ami c'est ta faute charles le
monde va basculer
je suis désolé de n'avoir rien fait
avant tu es toujours désolé chat puis
toujours tu te justifie mais ça
n'intéresse plus personne
il ya encore de l'espoir
ne faites pas ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les ont raison mais crown
j'ai vu le ballon
et je le vois maintenant
[Applaudissements]